let's have a look at these answers
4 minus i times 2 plus 3i so you had a
look at multiplying complex numbers in
very basic forms
before so this is pretty stock standard
we've got an answer here do we have
agreement we had to get it checked right
are you happy with 11 plus 10i
yeah um just before we we leave off it
let's just do one line of working
together make sure we know what we're
doing right
this is just like normal like if
everything was all real numbers we could
handle the arithmetic
very similarly right so i'm going to
distribute this four across to these two
and then i'm going to distribute this
minus i across to these two so you're
going to get
first line help me out 8 plus what
12i fantastic minus 2i minus
3i squared are you happy with that okay
so you can see hopefully even this line
itself is enough of a check you're like
okay
you'll very quickly start to realize if
you lay these out in the way we normally
would expand things you'll get your two
imaginary terms there in the middle
looks good
and then this guy here you're watching
for your double negatives all the time
because that's kind of what we get out
of imaginary numbers when you raise them
to powers
that's going to be our 8 plus 3. happy
with that as well
now um i'm not even gonna do the you
know the line immediately previously
this but what's our mechanism for
dealing with division you can't just
divide through
the way we do with real numbers what's
the first thing that you do
yeah i have to realize this denominator
right so we multiply by what we call
that thing again
the conjugate i'm going to um push on us
a little bit if you've got your notes
there from last lesson we've been saying
the conjugate we really should be
calling it the
complex conjugate okay because it's not
three plus it's 3
minus i that we're multiplying by and so
it's the imaginary part
that's sort of changing so it's the
complex conjugate so we should
be particular with that language
do we end up there 9 over 5 minus 3 over
five i
can't do that thumbs up okay by the way
whoever wrote this um solution
uh great job one of the things you might
have been wanting to do at the beginning
is just leave it as
nine minus three i divided by five and
that's the correct answer by the way i
should point out
however we tend to want to write these
as the real part
completely separate to the imaginary
part okay
so this is even though you've got the
same denominator there the customary way
we'll write this so
thumbs up all right let's have a quick
check through
here i'm just going to do the working
for this first one right when we
multiply through by
i just the first time right we're
starting with this number so we
multiply the first thing by i and then
we multiply the second thing by i and i
think you're
happy to see that that's going to end up
as negative 2. so i'm happy to confirm
that
you then get these successive answers
what do you get
when you simplify this guy because you
don't even need to write down
like five or two this looks familiar
doesn't it what answer did you get
did you get two i plus five you got z1
in other words so i'm just going to
leave that there
as our um as our answer we will return
to these
four numbers a bit later on in the
lesson for now
you've made the heading starter
questions can you make a new heading
which is
refining
language and notation
and it's the 16th isn't it
okay so let's review we introduced this
idea of complex numbers
as kind of our version of those little
water molecules that were bouncing
around
those bigger molecules we could see
vibrating jiggling about you're like why
is it doing that there's something
invisible
acting on those and that was my
comparison for you'd have to write this
down
for when you have a quadratic like this
and we did the sum and product of roots
right and you're like oh
i'm going to get a sum of
negative 2 and i'm going to get a
product of 4 despite the fact that i
can't see where those roots are we would
have normally said or they don't exist
then we said well if we if we expand our
number system to include these
otherwise invisible numbers then we can
see why when you add those two complex
roots together you'll get this
when you multiply those two complex
roots together you get this we went
ahead and proved that right
now why is it this is not a rhetorical
question why is it that those water
molecules
were invisible for so long like why did
no one
think there might be smaller things than
what we can see
under the microscope any suggestions
like this is actually a practical
question
why was it invisible any takers
who who does a science here in stage six
just a quick show hands first
okay most of you fantastic thank you
hands down what do you reckon what was
the reason why they're invisible
yeah you had your hand up before right
yeah oh because at first and
back in like engine years the scale of
measuring
measurement is very high you can't get
um very accurate results therefore we're
only concerned about microscopic things
yeah for sure microscopic world or how
it might effectively microscope
yeah that i think that's that's perfect
right it's a question of scale isn't it
these things are just
too small they're too small in fact even
now we're just barely pushing
the boundaries of our microscopy that we
can see
water molecules right and they're like
super blurry because these things are
just so small
they're like so think about the
wavelength of light and how small that
is
and then the things we're trying to look
at right so these
things were invisible for a different
reason though it's not to do with scale
and by the end of this lesson
we're going to understand why they're
invisible but to get to there we need to
be able to talk about and use notation
that will describe all these things
we've introduced some of it
but we need more okay so underneath this
uh
let's go back to something you can write
this a little larger because we're going
to
attach some things to it let's go back
to the way that we described every
complex number as you can see on the
board right
it has these two separate components
right so we would write it our customary
way
is to write it like so um i gotta go
question um last lesson about like do we
put the i
first or the i second the short answer
is you'll see it in both of those
positions so don't worry about it too
much
um it depends kind of on the purpose of
what we're gonna do with this and we'll
um
we'll highlight that as we go along we
want to add some more
language and notation here right so
firstly let's talk about this guy over
here that number that you see out the
front this is what we call
the real component right and sometimes
we want to just talk about
the real component without writing the
words real
components so our shorthand for that is
if you have some complex numbers in and
you just want the real part
we use this notation right
what is the real component of z
it's going to be that number a okay
now when we talk about the other part
there's a slight difference here
this including the eye
this is our imaginary component
but when we think about the sort of
converse of this guy
right um what by the way what notation
do you think we would use if this is how
we refer to the real component
how do you think we refer to the
imaginary component just take a stab in
the dark
i am right um sometimes sometimes we use
completely random things like
what's our our premium rule for gradient
i know
m right sometimes it's like why is that
this time at least it's reasonably
sensible
when we're looking for the imaginary
point of z this is slightly weird
we actually just mean the coefficient
in front of that so these two things
these two things are slightly different
okay so we mean the imaginary component
is the whole thing
so these here are connected clearly
right the imaginary component is
bi but when i write this i just mean b
what's that coefficient there
okay so that follows that if i
say the real component here if that's
zero what that means is you've just got
this part here do you agree with that
right if that's zero so we would call
this a purely imaginary
number a purely imaginary number because
there's no real component
uh and in just the same way if this guy
if b is zero
then what do you think we call that not
purely imaginary it's purely
real right
now it's also customary to point out
that both a and b
are coefficients in this case they're
both real numbers themselves
a is a real number b how many lots of
this imaginary unit is also
a real number so in this case you know
our b would be 10
our b would be negative three-fifths
right so the way we write that our
notation to refer to the fact that a and
b
are both real numbers is we would say
note
a and b are do you recognize this
from earlier in the year this is our the
formal way to say this is is an element
of
the real number set but the way i read
this is
a and b they're real numbers that's
essentially the way that i'll interpret
that okay
so this if we define z to be any complex
number
like that if i had some other complex
number and you saw before
this is the reason like why did we
choose this letter but anyway if we had
some other number
uh that was complex that was called w
okay
if the real component of this other
complex number
was the same as the real component of
this complex number
and if the imaginary part of
this new complex number is the same as
their imaginary part
of our original complex number these are
the two defining characteristics
of your number so if they're both the
same what you can conclude is therefore
this first complex number is the same as
the other one
right if the real components match the
imaginary components match
then they're the same complex number
okay